this Alex Jones trial is crazy
in the beginning I was like when he got
sued for four million dollars I was like
oh man that's a lot but he did uh
[ __ ] you know cause these families a
lot of pain and [ __ ] and suffering
um and a lot of these like one of the
ladies had to move 10 times or something
because his this is the [ __ ] thing
about people say Free Speech it's like
okay so the guy thinks that uh
Sandy Hook is a hoax
that's just one of those things that
it's like if you were in a [ __ ]
someone's party
and you just kept saying this
not on a podcast just like in someone's
living room
and everyone was just like it was New
Year's and everyone was just like it was
like that [ __ ] you know
everyone was just listening to music
and then [ __ ] this [ __ ] in the
corner are just like you know that the
[ __ ] Sandy Hook thing is just uh
you know it didn't actually exist right
you they'd be like what
everyone else in the party be like what
maybe there'll be one or two other guys
that were like that were swayable
because they're [ __ ] made you know
they're like oh you make a lot of really
good points but they're also kind of
drunk too
and the music's just playing and it's
[ __ ] and the guy all night is just
trying to get people you know if the
Sandy Hook thing is that the [ __ ]
they think it was a a what they call a
red flag what they call it a [ __ ]
false flag you know about those right
those kids weren't even real right a lot
of those parents didn't even have kids
if you look into it if you do your own
research
that's the thing man it's a false flag
and then [ __ ] all right dude it's
it's cool man all good it's just three
two hey you're thinking about Sandy Hook
one happy new year
yeah dude it's great it's a new year but
it's just another year where everybody
thinks that [ __ ] Sandy Hook thing
happened
well they're all acquaintance speaking
of acquaintances I heard that the
acquaintance they weren't even
acquaintances let alone their [ __ ]
children dude that guy would get his
[ __ ]
[ __ ] handed to him
enough's enough dude the guy would get
their ass kicked and now all these
people online can just pop up Papa at
the [ __ ] mouth
and this is how you remedy that
situation the defaming the [ __ ] you
you get you get four million dollars
taken from you and then the second one
he now has to pay [ __ ] 49 million
dollars hey I'm the mathematician but
that's over 50 million dollars and then
there's like three or four more [ __ ]
things he's got to do the guy's [ __ ]
just basically here's the rule
even on the internet
don't pop off at the mouth
right
because there's consequences
if you're popping off at the [ __ ]
mouth you're gonna get punched in the
proverbial mouth one way or another
whether you're that [ __ ] at the party
or you're that [ __ ] online talking
about conspiracies
stop bitching dude
whatever happened to that [ __ ] no
snitching shirt remember stop snitching
get that [ __ ]
remember that [ __ ] stop snitching that
shirt with the [ __ ] and everyone that
[ __ ] went nuts for a little bit it was
like 2001 and then all of a sudden
everyone's just like nah but snitch
you don't know
you don't know what really happened
that's so that's my whole thing dude
like and I'm not saying yeah okay sure
some conspiracy theories do turn out to
be true of course it would be [ __ ]
irresponsible to say they're all not
true but like some of them do tend to be
true just like sometimes when you hit on
when you're playing Blackjack and you
hit on [ __ ] uh 20 you might get an
ace
it's not likely but it could happen it's
like that you know
so like
I don't know this guy is [ __ ] man
what a martyr for these [ __ ]
people who believe in lizard people
uh I mean he literally thinks that
[ __ ] uh Barack Obama and uh Hillary
Clinton are lizards so all good
and when they go in the ocean frogs
become gay that's what he said
congratulations
[Music]
[Music]